[MUSIC]
I have spent my career so far working and
living in two very different worlds.
The first is the world of politics,
where I wrote speeches and
made ads on two presidential campaigns.
The second is the world of business,
where I led special projects
at a major technology company.
I get asked the exact same
question all the time.
So tell me, do the politicians and
the CEOs really hate each other as much as
they look like they do on TV when they're
screaming at each other all the time?
That question makes me really sad.
It makes me sad because it says
something about our society that
everyone just kind of assumes
that our political leaders and
our business leaders despise each other.
But you know what makes me even sadder?
It's actually more true
than I would like to admit.
Because I've seen firsthand how this
collapsing relationship between our
political leaders and
our business leaders.
This lack of decency, this lack of
respect, this lack of fundamental
communication, is causing
massive problems for society.
Just look around.
It's no secret that things
are pretty screwed up.
Our planet is literally on fire.
Our democracies teetering on the edge, and
people all around us are angry for
good reason.
We are facing a set of three once
in many generation challenges.
The first is climate change,
the second is weakening belief
in democracy, and
the third is widespread inequality.
And these aren't just government problems,
and
they're not just business problems,
they are everyone problems.
And while most of us inherently
understand this, we don't talk about
the next logical step,
which is to solve these problems, we first
need to fix the broken relationship
between business and government.
So what are these problems
that we need to solve?
I know it's hard talking about
difficult issues like these.
So I find it's helpful to
talk about specific stories.
So let's do that for each of these three.
First, let's talk about the climate.
For decades, California has been allowed
by the federal government to set
stricter car emission standards
than the rest of the country.
But when President Trump came into office,
he got into a lawsuit with the state of
California to stop this from happening.
General Motors, along with several other
car makers, signed on to this lawsuit and
actively encouraged
President Trump to get involved.
But then, on November 7th 2020,
President Biden won the 2020 election and
just 16 days later,
General Motors made a big announcement.
They said they were dropping
their support of the lawsuit and
were thrilled to work with the new
administration to tackle climate change.
What does it tell us about our society?
That one of the biggest companies in
the country changed its mind on one
of the most important problems facing our
society just because an election happened.
Ask yourself, is that what bold,
values-driven corporate
leadership looks like?
Second, let's talk about the heart
of those elections, our democracy.
Most of us here have probably
seen political ads online.
In fact, some of you may even hate them.
In which case I'm really sorry,
some of them are definitely my fault.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
some of you may have heard of something
called the Federal Election Commission,
or the FTC, the government agency
responsible for regulating political ads.
But here's what you may not know,
the last time that the FTC updated its
regulations on online political
ads was in the year 2006.
Yes, 2006,
that was back before a tiny company
called Facebook was even
open to the public and
a full five years before
Snapchat was even founded.
So online political ads right now
are pretty much the Wild West.
And it's gotten so bad in recent cycles
that the platforms like Google and
Facebook have had to step in and
set their own rules because
the FTC was not doing its job.
Ask yourself,
is that what strong government
oversight of the business
world looks like?
Third, let's talk about our
last generational challenge,
widespread inequality.
A few years ago,
DoorDash had an unusual tipping policy.
Dashers would go out and deliver food and
DoorDash would guarantee
them a minimum payment to ensure
that if a customer did not tip them,
they would still bring
a certain amount home.
That's a great idea, but
if a customer did tip them, DoorDash
would lower their payment to the dasher
by the exact same amount as the tip.
So DoorDash was basically like,
thank you very much for the money, and
put it in its pocket.
There was a huge uproar
when this came out.
The CEO apologized,
the policy was changed.
And while nothing indicates that
this was purposely malicious,
ask yourself, where were the government
regulators who should have been
making rules to ensure that everyone in
the gig economy could earn a fair wage?
And where were the corporate
executives who could have spoken to
Dashers to understand how this
policy would have impacted them?
Now that we've talked
through these three examples,
I would bet there's at least one
person in this audience who's
thinking something like this,
geez, this guy's kind of naive.
What does he expect?
That all these folks in
the political world and
all these folks in the business
world are just going to get along?
Come on, live in reality.
They have such opposing interests.
And that's a fair point.
Believe me, I've heard it before.
But here is what that argument misses.
Our political leaders and
our business leaders have one very
common interest, and
that's keeping a stable society.
And a stable society
includes a stable planet,
a stable democracy, and a stable people.
Because here is a fundamental truth,
you cannot make money and
you cannot govern, in the long run,
when everything around you is going crazy.
That's why these aren't just
government problems and
they're not just business problems.
They are everyone problems and
it is naive, incredibly,
ridiculously, laughably naive, to believe
that we can keep a stable society for
decades into the future when
our political leaders and
our business leaders cannot even
approach each other with goodwill.
But here's the good news,
things are changing.
Rebecca Henderson,
a professor at Harvard Business School,
has been writing over the past few
years about the need to re-imagine
capitalism to fight climate change.
And Larry Fink, the leader of one of
the world's largest asset managers,
has been writing, recently, about the need
for companies to find profit and purpose.
But we need all of our
leaders to take action.
And that's where everyone
here today comes in.
Because remember both of those
companies that I just talked about,
General Motors and DoorDash, well,
their CEOs are both Stamford MBA alumni.
So that means in ten years,
maybe even five, you could be them.
So here's what we need to do.
First, for all the business leaders here
today, before making a big decision,
ask yourself this question,
in ten years from now will this
decision make society a better place or
a worse place?
You might be surprised how many
decisions have a clear-cut
answer to that very simple question.
Second, for all the political leaders
here, before making a big decision,
ask yourself this question,
in ten years from now,
will this decision help those companies
make the right choices for society?
Because your job is to set the market's
rules to incentivize those
businesses to make good decisions
not just for their shareholders,
but for all of us and
especially your constituents.
Third, for all the students here today,
the future leaders,
there is a change coming to the way
business interacts with the wider world.
If you listen closely
you can hear it coming.
Think deeply about the role you
have to play in that movement.
Think about the companies you join and
the projects you take on,
because they really do matter.
Fourth, and this is for everyone here,
do not wait for
someone else to take the lead.
We do not have the time to waste.
We all need to get started on this today.
Because remember,
these aren't just government problems and
they're not just business problems.
They are everyone problems, and
we need to work together to solve them.
So if you're sitting here today and you're
already worried about what the planet
is going to look like for your kids, or
you can't even imagine what's going to
happen in the next election, or you walk
down the street and are horrified by
the inequality you see all around you,
you already know how high the stakes are.
So what are you going to do about it?
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]